c'est dire que c'est pratiquement
impossible de vraiment vérifier qu'un
engin atomique ne pourrait pas entrer
dans une ville
ça va 100 millions de lecteurs mesdames
messieurs ça fait du monde hein quand
même hein tu entends Lolita
paris brûle-t-il ou tu porteras mon
deuil oh Jérusalem cette nuit la liberté
le cinquième cavalier 100 millions de
lecteurs 10 millions d'exemplaires bravo
alors aujourd'hui c'est le grand retour
de la pierre et Collins 20 ans après
comme les comme les Mousquetaires avec
New York brûle-t-il qui est un livre
absolument époustouflant mais je crois
que ce qui est merveilleux Thierry si on
peut le dire c'est comment nous sommes
revenus ensemble après 24 ans de
séparation c'est qu'on a été les amis
toujours depuis 50 ans on s'est
rencontré pendant notre service
militaire et puis un jour on s'est réuni
et puis pendant 7 ans on a été
absolument concurrent sur les routes du
monde un jour la rime enfermée dans ma
chambre d'hôtel à Bagdad parce que je
travaillais pour Paris Match pour
m'empêcher d'envoyer les photos de la
Révolution irakienne et lui travaillait
à newsoui qu'il a été le seul à avoir
ses photos je me suis vengé quelques
semaines plus tard en lui donnant un
faux horaires de chemin de fer pour un
train qui partait de Djibouti vers
Addis-Abeba et j'ai été le dernier
interviewer le Négus et un jour on s'est
mis ensemble et on a écrit la plus belle
histoire franco-américaine la libération
de Paris et ça a été et on a fait donc
ces cinq livres dont vous parlez et
pourquoi vous êtes séparés alors en 1981
moi j'ai eu un coup de foudre pour
l'Inde et particulièrement pour une
vieille dame un peu ridée avec un sari
bordé de bleu qui s'appelle la mère
Teresa dans un bidonville de Calcutta et
là j'ai découvert les gens tellement
extraordinaires que je me suis dit je
vais faire un livre sur ces héros ces
héros du tiers monde qui nous donne tout
parce qu'ils ont l'espérance le courage
la capacité de partager avec plus pauvre
que je savais que Larry n'aimerait pas
passer deux années dans un bidonville de
Calcutta c'est vrai absolument raison il
avait lui-même un projet de livre et
j'ai donc écrit la cité de la joie et
puis on a fait quatre cinq livres
séparément et dans justement dans le
sillage du 11 septembre on s'est dit
parce qu'on se retrouve toujours et
pourquoi est-ce qu'on essaye pas
d'écrire un nouveau livre ensemble mais
cette fois pas un livre d'histoire un
roman qui serait au cœur de et si Ben
Laden aller plus loin que d'envoyer des
avions sur les tours de New York s'il
mettait une bombe atomique dans la ville
de New York et qu'il donnait ses cinq
jours au président de cinq jours au
président des États-Unis pour faire
pression sur Israël pour évacuer les
territoires arabes
occupés mais il fallait savoir d'abord
si c'était plausible nous voulions faire
quelque chose d'absolument réel alors on
a fait une enquête mondiale pour
découvrir est-ce que Ben Laden pourrait
avoir une bombe atomique et Larry peut
vous raconter que au Pakistan on a fait
des découvertes absolument incroyable
sur Daniel perle c'est-à-dire qu'il y
avait une bombe pakistanaise qui en fait
était une bombe islamique exactement
aujourd'hui le 30 mars dans l'arsenal
pakistanais et surtout ce qui est
intéressant et inquiétant c'est bon sont
sous le garde d'un petit code élite de
l'armée pakistanais
qui est complètement infiltré par les
islamistes extrémistes voilà alors je
reprends donc trois ans après le 11
septembre les terroristes cachent une
bombe au cœur de New York et si le
président des États-Unis n'oblige pas
les Israéliens à quitter les colonies
dans les territoires arabes occupés
Manhattan sera rayé de la carte c'est
c'est le pitch de votre histoire les
terroristes donnent 5 jours aux
Américains pour le faire sinon New York
sera transformé en un nouvel Hiroshima
il est trop tard pour évacuer la ville
le compte à rebours commence alors
évidemment tout le monde se demande quel
doit être la réaction d'Arielle Sharon
et Ariel Sharon dit je peux pas accepter
ce chantage sinon c'est la c'est la fin
d'Israël il y a même un moment où les
américains s'apprêtent à attaquer à
intervenir dans la bande de Gaza
cette enquête c'est de découvrir que
tout était vrai d'abord c'est bon on
parle Larry est-ce qu'elle pourrait une
dette pourrait sortir du Pakistan et
aller vers New York alors on est allé au
fond du désert du Rajasthan à la
frontière entre l'Inde Pakistan la nuit
pour découvrir les caravanes de chameau
qui transportent la drogue d'un pays à
l'autre et sur un de ces chameaux peut
transiter cette bombe atomique environ
120 kg oui c'est bon de Pakistanais et
alors la caravane passe la frontière
arrive dans ce désert incroyable du
Rajasthan jusque cette ville de
gesselmyre de la le monde dans une
camionnette et va bomber et là des gens
la mettent dans un container et on
s'aperçoit aujourd'hui qu'il y a 5000
containers qui arrivent chaque jour dans
un port comme celui de New York et
seulement 2% sont contrôlés c'est-à-dire
même pas une centaine parce que tout le
commerce international aujourd'hui se
fait par ses containers donc d'envoyer
un tel engin dans cette ville de New
York c'est un jeu d'enfant et ce qui est
vraiment terrible c'est que nous nous
avons dépensé nous américains nous
américains oui mais pas moi 87 milliards
de dollars peut faire la guerre
et l'année dernière on a des pensées 40
millions de dollars seulement
votre bouquin c'est que c'est possible
quoi c'est vrai tout est véridique
disons non mais vous avez pas peur de
donner des
deux de donner des idées
[Musique]
à des gens écrit deux fois disons que
les islamistes devraient s'armer avec
des bandes nucléaires nous le savions
qu'il a rencontré deux fois à Cabourg le
père de la bombe pakistanais
on n'a pas des leçons à donner à au sein
mais il a raison
on s'est aperçu que les Américains
avaient mis au point des petits gadgets
pour détecter les radiations atomiques
ils les ont placé tout autour de New
York à l'entrée de tous les péages des
tunnels des ponts et tout ça mais ils
sont plus ils sont plus en service mais
alors ils sont plus en service c'est
pourquoi ils sont plus en service parce
que pendant les 8 premiers mois où ils
étaient en service ils ont enregistré
70000 alertes de gens qui sortaient d'un
hôpital après cette fait faire une
chimiothérapie ou une radio thérapie les
flics devenaient absolument fou et
finalement on a tout débranché c'est
dire que c'est pratiquement impossible
de vraiment vérifier qu'un engin
atomique ne pourrait pas entrer dans une
ville
scénario de l'Apocalypse
on a donné beaucoup de boulot elle
arrive pour faire
Jérusalem on va lui donner encore un peu
oh New York il va faire au New York on
veut pas qu'il soit attention mal c'est
une bombe atomique explosé à New York ça
ferait quoi un million de morts tout est
calculé alors on a on a découvert des
fonctionnaires extraordinaires qui
avaient passé leur vie à déterminer que
sur la 71e rue il resterait 7
vétérinaires quatre infirmières et tout
ça tout ça est complètement faux c'est
ça mais un million 200000 morts si elle
était placé au centre et si le vent
souffle de la mer c'est toute la mairie
qui est
tous les États-Unis environnement et ce
qui est quand même encore formidable
pendant les années de guerre froide on a
dépensé des millions des millions de
dollars on peut construire des des abris
contre les armes nucléaires
antiatomiques oui alors qu'est-ce que tu
as rêvé ces abris à Thomas aromatique il
avait une dizaine des années il y avait
un tremblement de terre Nicaragua très
gentil on a travaillé chercher tous les
provisions qui étaient là dedans on les
envoie un écureuil tous les gens qui
l'ont mangé ont tombé malade et on a
visité un de ses abris alors il y a une
pancarte de la Sécurité Civile
Américaine qui date de la guerre froide
on voit conseil à suivre en cas de
risque d'explosion atomique alors on
voit ouvrez la fenêtre ensuite on voit
des fêtes le col de votre cravate et
puis mettez-vous dans la position du
fœtus il y a comme ça 10 recommandations
et la dernière c'est merveilleux à une
question as goodbye et donner à baiser à
Dieu à votre cul
donc c'est tout à fait des choses qui
sont d'aujourd'hui alors après vous
dites que grâce à un flic un peu plus
malin que les autres on arrive à s'en
sortir
des situations on a rencontré une fois
en septembre
on a rencontré une fille formidable qui
s'appelle Gladys une Américaine de 35
ans très haut niveau de scientifiques si
dans un cas pareil elle était appelée ce
serait elle une fois que la bombe aura
été retrouvée qui sera chargé de la
désamorcer
une bombe à New York c'est comme une
aiguille dans une machine il faut lire
parce que c'est là l'enquête policière
qui est formidable c'est là le thriller
mais là dans cette histoire il y a deux
crampes de grands problèmes à résoudre
le premier comment trouver le bon et ça
justement à la fin de la journée c'est
le boulot
comme un flic parisien qui connaît sa
ville qui connaît ses quartiers qui
connaît les machines on a trouvé un prix
comme ça à New York assez des jours avec
lui on peut visiter toute son territoire
mais après le chose le plus dangereux et
le plus difficile comme il disait c'est
de amorcer bon et ça on a mis le tâches
entre les mains d'une femme de 35 ans
que j'ai passé tout l'après-midi avec
elle à Washington c'est
et elle fait partie comme elle monte une
organisation qui est chargée avec la
responsabilité d'arrêter les bandes et
de les décès à Marseille et si elle se
trouve devant cette bombe c'est avec la
connaissance que si elle fait une erreur
elle peut le faire exposer
d'en prendre de la graine Carcassonne je
peux te dire qu'il serait fier de toi si
tu vendais il est parti ici tu vas
emmener ton bouquin comme il vendent
300 interview 3 ans 500 kg de documents
gros boulot moi c'est difficile parfois
on est tous seuls au bout du monde
téléphoner et puis on se disait voilà
j'ai rencontré quelqu'un qui est
formidable tu devrais peut-être aller
voir cette autre personne qui nous a
indiqué c'est d'abord une documentation
monstrueuse on aurait pu écrire 10
livres avec tout ce qu'on a rapporté on
nous arrivons de Madrid là où le livre
vient de sortir en Espagne c'était très
très bouleversant d'être avec tous ces
gens encore traumatisés par cette
attentat et quand nous avons vu nous les
les dessins du système des systèmes
d'explosion qui ont eu lieu à Madrid
parce que une bombe sur les 10 n'a pas
explosé parce que l'artificier avec son
téléphone cellulaire s'est trompé il y a
sur le téléphone PM l'après-midi ou em
le matin toutes les bombes ont explosé à
7h46 du matin lui il s'est trompé il a
mis PM elle devait sauter à 7h46 le soir
donc on a pu retrouver cette bombe et
c'était exactement
le système de mise à feu que nous avons
imaginé dans New yorking quand ce cher
ben la j'espère que l'avenir vous
donnera pas trop raison parce que nous
espérons est-ce que le bouquin est sorti
aux États-Unis non pas encore pas encore
il va sortir
sur ce titre de New Yorks il va sortir
sur le titre et donc aller sauver New
York c'est une phrase du commissaire
principal de New York à tous ces flics
pour le dit maintenant c'est à vous de
sauver New York toute la technologie
complètement
et si ça pouvait alerter nos chefs
politiques nos responsables de la
sécurité de leur dire qui nous mentent
qui nous protège pas qui font pas ce
qu'il faut pour empêcher ses actions
terroristes ce serait déjà un grand pas
en avant grâce à ce livre New York
ultime non je voulais savoir ça peut
arriver évidemment à Paris à Rome dans
n'importe quelle ville
à Londres quand ils ont arrêté
avec des liens avec les islamistes et un
demi-tonne de matériel qui pouvait se
dire comme les exposés des
renseignements venant dukraine après au
monde que des ogives nucléaires de
l'Arsenal la nucléaire ukrainien ont
disparu où sont-elles dans les mains de
qui sont-elles fantastiques personne
donc il y en a une qui a disparu l'autre
jour le président bouche a fait un grand
discours devant une grande partère des
milances américaines pour leur dire le
plus grand danger aujourd'hui c'est le
terrorisme nucléaire à l'intérieur d'une
ville j'avais l'impression qu'il lisait
une page de New York wiltyle je voulais
après son discours l'appeler au
téléphone et lui dire au nom de Larry et
nous est-ce que vous accepteriez
d'écrire une préface pour nous
clairement on n'est pas protégé
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a aucun moyen pour
l'espionnage la CIA le l'OSS ça c'est le
meilleur moyen mais il n'y a pas
insécurité totale le plus important
pas vers cet état de sécurité c'est de
tâcher de désamorcer les choses qui
poussent les terroristes vers le terreur
Dominique A Calcuta il a compris que le
pauvreté est un des moteurs derrière
cette de l'année Larry est-ce que
réellement on peut considérer
aujourd'hui que si les problèmes en
Palestine étaient réglés et ailleurs
est-ce que les terrorisme mondial
arrêterait ça ne va pas
énormément
de l'Occident ce serait une une partie
en tous les cas c'est époustouflant
bravo
vous frappez encore merci et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de inarritube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu